Maybe you should just take some time apart.
You never even wanted to do anything anymore.
And every time I bring something up, you're always fricking quiet. Like,
it's just like, you don't even like me anymore.
You want to just fricking leave. Oh,
okay. Well let's do something like fricking crazy tonight.
Be spontaneous. I'm trying to sleep.
You never want to have fun anymore. Like,
you're like a freaking grandpa. I want to party.
I want to like do stuff. Okay.
Sarah
Miami's party or this tonight let's reach. Okay.
What do you mean? Okay. What was fricking party?
And let's get in party mode like we're young and growing out.
Take it seriously
for me. Cheers. Cheers.
Crazy again. Just take care of me.
There we go.
Wait, wait.
[inaudible] are you hungry? Pasta.
Do you think yogurt goes to with pasta? Sure. Yeah. Sure.
Ooh. Ooh.
You're freaking murder.
[inaudible]
couch cleanup.
The game. You should live stream this.
This is yours.
Do you even lift bro?
You're going to have fun.
Go snap. This pic here. Miro right quick.